So there is devastating, just devastating
new evidence in the [inaudible]
Trump Ukraine quid pro quo fiasco and it is
really important to understand what we mean
by evidence and I think this is really worth
doing. So I'm going to focus on that element
today and I hope that this is useful. Uh,
there is new testimony under oath from the
United States Envoy to the Ukraine who says
that, listen, the story we've been getting
publicly is true. Donald Trump indeed made
the security aid hundreds of millions of dollars
in security aid to Ukraine contingent on dependent
upon Ukraine publicly saying that they were
going to carry out this politically motivated
smear investigation against Joe and Hunter
Biden. That is as a fact, not very surprising
to people in my audience, I presume who had
been following the story. But this is the
really important part that I want to focus
on today. If we go back to the Russia probe
and carry through to what is going on now
with Ukraine and the impeachment inquiry.
The Trump is right has insisted time and time
again that there is no evidence that everything
that there is in the Trump Russia probe with
the Ukraine fiasco, it is hearsay and peoples
baseless allegations and this is why we have
to be just super crystal clear here because
unless we're prepared to address this farcical
claim, they're going to get away with it.
Okay? Testimony under oath is evidence. Now
there is a difference between evidence and
sort of caught red handed, irrefutable proof,
but before we even get to that we have to
understand how they are distorting what actually
counts as evidence. And before I go into this,
let me give you an analogy which I think is
useful here. Consider the word theory. Okay.
The word theory has one meaning in colloquial
usage and it has another meaning in the world
of science. In science when the, when the
term theory is used, we're talking about a
group of propositions that explain facts or
explain some real world phenomena.
For example, the theory of evolution that
has a very specific meaning in the world of
science, but the word theory in popular culture
and colloquial usage has a different meaning
and theory in colloquial usage often actually
means what in science is called the hypothesis,
which is it's sort of like a starting point
or it's a possibility. It's one of many possibilities
for explaining something in the real world
and one of the things that the American right-wing
loves to do is, for example, in the context
of climate change, deliberately misstate or
flip between definitions of what they mean
by theory. They'll just deliberately distort
the definition of theory by switching back
and forth between the scientific definition
and the colloquial usage, which really means
hypothesis. They'll say, you know a theory
about climate change. A theory is just one
of 2030 or 40 different explanations about
what's going on.
We'll hold on a second. That may be what it
means in colloquial usage, but when science
calls something a theory, it has a different
meaning. Now, let's go back to this evidence
thing. Bearing in mind this analogy from a,
you know, theory hypothesis all along Republicans
have said there is no evidence for anything
in the Russia probe. There is no evidence
of any quid pro quo in the Ukraine fiasco.
Sometimes they'll also use the word hearsay.
They'll say it's all hearsay. What they mean
is no one has been caught on video in a cartoonish
out of the movies, sort of red handed way
that satisfies them as irrefutable proof.
But here's the really important thing. Sworn
testimony is evidence. William Taylor, the
United States Envoy to Ukraine provided sworn
testimony to lawmakers where he says there
is no question that Donald Trump was withholding
aid in order to try to get Ukraine to smear
Joe Biden and Hunter Biden publicly.
So now the Trumpists are coming in and they're
saying, hold on a second. What William Taylor
says is not evidence. It's merely hearsay,
which is also the wrong word, but let's forget
that for now. We're not going to get into
hearsay right now. Sworn testimony is evidence.
Sworn testimony is evidence made under oath
or affirmation under penalty of perjury. Now
someone could give sworn testimony and belying
someone could give sworn testimony and not
remember the facts correctly. But when the
right says there is no evidence, that's either
a lie or an ignorant understanding of what
evidence means. The testimony is evidence.
But here's where the theory versus hypothesis
thing comes back to be useful. They're also
using evidence interchangeably with proof.
This is the other game that they're playing.
William Taylor giving evidence that Donald
Trump withheld aid in a quid pro quo for Joe
Biden to be smeared is not irrefutable proof
that that took place.
And that's okay. But what they are often saying
when they say there is no evidence is that
it is not irrefutable proof, which is a completely
different standard. It's a completely different
issue. So now understanding this, all of this
relates to the total and complete lack of
critical thinking and epistemology skills
in our society, which I have been sounding
the alarm about for years at this point. When
people understand how are made, when people
understand how to figure out for themselves.
If the words being used to describe things
are the most accurate and precise words that
can be used. You can't trick people like this.
The climate change theory, hypothesis games,
the games around what counts as evidence versus
proof. You can only get traction with distortions
and lies. You can only confuse people semantically
when people don't have the skills to think
these things through for themselves and that's
really the tragedy.
That's really the saddest thing of all about
the status quo of American [inaudible] ability
to think critically. Now, some last thoughts
about the substance of the testimony from
William Taylor, the U S Envoy to Ukraine just
to kind of come full circle and and do at
least some small analysis of that. Although
it doesn't really warrant much of an analysis
because we know what's going on. Number one,
the testimony is truly devastating to the
Trump narrative because everyone involved
who has given testimony, including testimony
about their knowledge of that Trump phone
call with the Ukrainian president. Even Mick
Mulvaney without realizing it, without meaning
to everyone, is confirming elements of the
story that the aid was contingent upon the
smears of Joe Biden. Now, after the fact,
they'll deny it. They'll try to go back and
again play semantic games about the definitions
of the words that they use, but that is the
trend.
Everybody's confirming the original story
even if they don't mean to. Secondly, this
also seems to have jump-started Fox news back
into state media mode where you know, we've
talked about, there have been recently some
disagreements between Fox news and Donald
Trump on some minor issues. The last 24 hours.
The testimony from William Taylor has completely
restarted Fox news. His narrative around the
entire Ukraine thing is a nothing burger.
It's all a smear attempt against Donald Trump.
It's all a witch hunt, et cetera. They covered
this story about William Taylor's testimony
as if the testimony from William Taylor is
obviously not credible and suggest that the
Trump witch hunt narrative is the correct
one, which I mean, imagine being that disconnected
from reality, that that's your takeaway. And
again, to go back to the conversation between
Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president,
the excerpt that was released, they initially
said it was a transcript.
Then they said, well, it's not a transcript.
It's a summation. In reality, it was a partial
transcript. Trump release that believing that
it vindicated him. Anyone who again, can think
for themselves can apply basic critical thinking
and epistemology skills to a document and
not be swayed by the story that Donald Trump
tells you about it. You realize that that
partial transcript is extraordinarily damning.
Uh, when it comes to Donald Trump's involvement
in this quid pro quo, we will see what the
future is of this entire thing. I know that
there are people in the audience who from
a practical perspective, are saying, listen,
David, I know you're right. And it's not just
you that's saying, I mean it's anybody who
analyzes the evidence, understands what it
is that took place here, but it is going to
be hard to get Trump on it and I don't disagree
with you.
And that's why all of these investigations,
all of these discussions, they need to be
properly contextualized in. Let's use them
to motivate voters to go out and vote for
someone other than Donald Trump. Because the
most likely scenario, I know that there are
other paths. The most likely scenario is none
of this stuff will forcefully remove Trump
from office. But if we play it correctly,
if we talk about it in the right way, it will
motivate voters to go out on November a of
whatever the date is, early November, 2020,
uh, and say no more. I'm voting for somebody
else. Let me know what you think. I'm on Twitter
at D Pacman. The show is on Twitter at David
Packard.
Let me check